libnam leader ed davey tweeted a video
of himself celebrating with a fist pump
when that result became clear now he
joins me again
um
sorry there you are uh
ed davey um you must be very cheerful
this morning congratulations is this the
um
start of the lib dem uh resurgence or is
it just the usual mid-term protest vote
that will disappear in the general
election
cleveland very excited by our victory
it's the second by-election victory for
the liberal democrats against the
conservatives this year that's not
happened since 1993
so i'm really proud of our party i'm
really proud of our campaigners and i
think we've brought hope to the whole
nation we've proven that conservatives
can be beaten anywhere and i think we
can confirm the reality if we're going
to get johnson the tories out of office
it's going to take the liberal democrats
beating conservative mps in their blue
wool seats
well when you say you can beat the
conservatives anywhere
let's just
talk a bit about the nature of your
campaign in north shropshire um we we
had a look at your election leaf ritz
leaflet uh sleaze was referenced 13
times christmas party scandal mentioned
just once healthcare is what you focused
on with 140 mentions in the leaflets
including 72 mentions of the ambulance
uh uh the station being moved from
austria to uh shrewsbury
uh mentioned 41 times essentially
you didn't really talk to the voters of
north shropshire about boris johnson at
all you focused on some local issues are
you going to do that everywhere and
expect to beat the conservatives
we focused on the issues that the voters
were concerned about it's the
westminster bubble who thinks it's all
about uh partygate and peppa pig and so
on we know different and the voters are
not shropshiring you differently
you did
no they raised it to us um i went on the
doorstep trevor i went to north
shropshire five times like i campaigned
for 10 days and in the early days way
before partygate what people were saying
they were worried about delays to
ambulance services i heard really sad
stories about people waiting in pain for
8 10 12 hours and we responded to that
so we looked at what the conservatives
have been doing on ambulance services
and they'd failed the people of north
shropshire the west midlands ambulance
services is in crisis and the
conservatives have done nothing about it
they've taken the people of north
shropshire as in so many parts of the
country totally for granted so i make no
apology for the liberal democrats
campaigning on health issues on farming
issues they were the issues that were
really important to the people of north
shropshire we will be a community
politics campaigning party not just in
north shropshire and cheshire amsterdam
with amazing by-election victories this
year but across the country there will
be many conservative mps now who are
really worried the little democrats now
are putting on a performance in
different parts of the country that is
the sort of things that saw the
conservatives thrown out of government
in 1997 for 13 years so you know i do
have a smile on my face i do think
there's new hope for our country and i
do think the conservatives are in real
trouble
but when you say davey that you can beat
the conservatives everywhere you're now
saying that you'll do that entirely
largely on the basis of what's happening
locally um doesn't that open you to the
traditional criticism of liberal
democrats that you will say one thing in
one constituency and say pretty much the
opposite next door if that's what suits
you locally
well that criticism has never been true
and it's not true now uh we're
campaigning on the health service in
constituencies around the country it's a
national issue and we're not um
campaigning on farming issues in urban
areas because there are no farms trevor
we campaign our farming issues in
farming areas where there are farmers
who want to know about our policies on
that our politics and farming are still
available to others of course um so i
think i think this argument that
sometimes pharmacy you tell the farmers
in north shropshire the lib dem
government would spend more money on
farming and you're telling
the voters in uh london urban
constituencies that you'll spend the
money on something different weren't you
no not at all we always put forward a
cost of manifesto which you publish for
the whole country and actually i think
my constituents are worried about what's
happening to britain's agriculture
actually because the tories are breaking
their promises they said they would put
in place a system to support our farmers
but actually taking that away before the
new system is coming place that's
another broken promise just like the
conservatives have broken promises on
the triple lock on pensions for example
on on leveling up and i think there's a
story about the conservatives they are
letting people down they said all these
things boris johnson settles at these
things and and he's not delivering they
have taken people for granted that is
why the liberal democrats won in north
shropshire why we dv1 in cheshire and
amisham and why i'm i'm so excited about
the prospects ahead of us now i think
there's a real chance of getting boris
johnson and the conservatives out of
power the next election and i think the
liberal democrats have shown the way
well let me put the same question to you
that i put to west streeting
surely the best chance of getting rid of
boris johnson and uh his party from
government would be if there were some
cooperation between the parties who all
seem to think the same thing about him
and his administration why aren't you
ready for an alliance with other parties
on the center and on the left
trevor let me first say that i'm really
grateful to traditional labour voters
lifelong labour voters
who in north shropshire indeed cheshium
liberal democrats their votes so we
could beat the conservatives it worked
but the issue really is allowing voters
to have those choices these choices are
organic in many ways you don't need a
form or even an informal pact or deal
voters can work out
which is the candidate best place to
beat the conservative mp during our
first past the post system and it
shouldn't be surprising anybody that
opposition party leaders want to see the
conservatives beaten and they're going
to put our resources where we think we
are the best uh vehicle for uh beating
the conservatives we will make our
positive case absolutely um but i think
people from other parties who know
where the liberal democrats are the
challenges they will come and back us
that's what that's what happened in
north rupture
uh davey uh well it looks like you're
gonna have a happy christmas thank you
very much for your time this morning
thank you